-President Trump
has been under fire recently
after reports surfaced that, o
several occasions,
he has spoken ill
of military veterans.
He denied the allegations
Friday, saying this.
-I've done more for the military
than almost anybody else.
-Here to talk about it is one of
our writers, Amber Ruffin.
-Hi, Seth.
-Hi, Amber.
It's so nice to have you bac
in the studio with us.
What do you think about
Trump saying
he's done more for the militar
than almost anyone else?
-I think he's correct.
And I should know.
Both my parents are veterans
-Oh, wow. So you don't disagre
with that statement.
-Why should I? It's true.
♪♪♪♪
-It is?
-It is.
-But how is that possible?
What has he done?
-What has Trump
done for the military?
Well, he said this.
He did that.
He did this and this and this.
Don't you forget about that.
♪♪♪♪
-But those are all bad things.
-He didn't say he's done
good things for the military
He just said,
"No one has done more."
And he's right.
No one has done more for
the military...
to make their lives worse.
♪♪♪♪
He said this.
He said that.
He said this and this and this
Don't you forget about that.
-Wait. That last one
was a good thing.
-It was a good thing,
but he didn't do it.
He did.
But that's not all.
♪♪♪♪
He also said this and this
This, this, and this.
And said that.
He said he did this.
But it turns out, he did not
♪♪♪♪
And don't you ever forget
for a teeny second
that that crazy old man
did this.
♪♪♪♪
♪♪ And thi-i-i-is ♪♪
-Wow. That's a lot.
So, you done?
Okay.
♪♪♪♪
-He did this.
He even said that.
He did this.
But most of all, he did this
That's what he did!
-Thanks, Amber.